welcome back so we're talking about
neural networks we've explored some of
the architecture some of the kind of
reasons why we can train such powerful
neural networks today some of the
applications and where it's going and
now I really think it's important to lay
out some cautionary tales some caveats
for neural networks now I'm really torn
I I think that there's a lot of hype
around neural networks unfortunately and
fortunately it's it's a great thing that
they're so easy to train but that also
means that I think a lot of people are
training them without really knowing
what's going on and how to kind of
validate their models and things like
that so I have this kind of mixed
feeling of great optimism there's a lot
going on that you know there's a lot of
evidence that neural networks are
powerful and will continue to be a major
major part of the machine learning
movement for for years to come a central
part but I also think that there are
major cautions that you have to keep in
mind especially when you apply these
neural networks to physical systems to
systems where human lives and safety or
at risk automation and I mean it's
happening so so we need to have this
discussion and I'm gonna be just as
brutal as I can so that we all are kind
of talking about the major burning
challenges that we have in making an
improving neural networks so this is not
kind of supposed to be a criticism of
neural networks but I want to get us
focused on the fact that there are key
issues that need ongoing development and
there's there's hundreds of people you
know working on these and that's that's
encouraging so us included okay one of
the first issues in neural networks that
I'll point out is overfitting okay it's
easy with this very expressive
architecture has so many degrees of
freedom it's kind of an over
parametrized system if you will that's
nice in the sense that it's good for
training and and has this flexibility of
expression but there's also the
potential for overfitting you can over
fit your neural network with all of
these knobs and bells and whistles to
your training data in a way that it
might not necessarily generalize
as well as you would like to the future
so this is again a really important
reason to cross validate your data and
in some applications and many
applications overfitting is not
necessarily an issue or something you
have to be concerned about because the
path data is very representative of the
future in fact everything I'll see in
the future you know is either an
interpolation or has analogs in my
previous training data and so as long as
I cross validate my model I will be fine
I'll have good high performance and in
fact those are the applications where
neural networks have typically really
you know shined is where you have huge
vast data sets that do generalize very
well to what you expect to see in the
future ok and I've heard a great analogy
before with overfitting professional
athletes in some sense there are certain
applications where you want to overfit
if you haven't you know NFL linebacker
you want them to be over fit for their
job you don't want them to be good at
other other things you want them to be
just super good at what they do and over
fit so maybe they're incredibly you know
the peak of their you know physical
specimen for what they do but maybe they
would have a hard time hiking up a
mountain that my kids could hike up I
don't know but you know there's this
idea that maybe overfitting is not bad
maybe what you want if you're a company
and you're trying to get 1% better
performance because that's millions or
billions of dollars of profit maybe you
want your model to be kind of over fit
as long as your past data is
representative of your future so I'm
abusing this term a little bit
overfitting is generally a bad thing but
there's some scenarios where if your
training data is rich enough and
generalizes to the future then as long
as you cross validate you know you're
you're gonna have good models for the
future so another thing I think is
really important for neural networks and
again this was in our general topic on
machine learning these are also
important is generalizability and this
is something that in general neural
networks tend to struggle with so
it's hard to learn physics it's hard to
learn Newton's second law you know if I
show you cannonball trajectories that's
great
but it's hard to learn something that
will generalize to building a rocket and
putting a human on the moon or in outer
space
okay so neural networks are great if
you've shown it what it's going to be
modeling in the future if you give it a
bunch of cannonball trajectories it'll
perfectly predict cannonball
trajectories but extracting out that
generalizable knowledge that F equals MA
kind of knowledge that in general is is
pretty tough and the examples that do it
are super impressive and and I think
this is where a lot of development is
going because you're gonna be putting
these neural networks in autonomous
systems they need a little bit more of a
rich and subtle and kind of abstract
understanding about the physics of the
world that they live in in addition
there is this idea of interpretability
and explained ability so again these
neural networks might have millions tens
of millions parameters of degrees of
freedom which makes them very expressive
but that also makes it sometimes very
hard to interpret what the neural
networks actually doing some
architectures are more interpretable
than others there's some ways in which
we're getting good at interpreting
neural networks but in general they
still kind of have this this feeling of
being a big black box that's a little
bit opaque and hard too hard to really
see how the gears are working inside and
with this increased push for explainable
machine learning an explainable AI you
know it's it's really important that we
can understand and tell other humans how
these algorithms are making decisions or
the algorithm should be explaining
itself that's important and then another
area this is kind of near and dear to my
heart is this idea that as an engineer
and as a scientist I'm not just working
with image classification dogs and cats
or speech recognition I work in a world
where we know physics we know that
energy is conserved and mass is
conserved we know that there are
symmetries and all of these interesting
laws that we've you know hundreds of
years of human knowledge we shouldn't be
throwing this away just be
there is a powerful new architecture we
would love to be able to bake in and
incorporate some of that partial
physical knowledge into these neural
networks we'd love to be able to take
data and learn new physics and I don't
mean this actually in just neural
networks this is true for machine
learning in general we'd love to be able
to figure out how to incorporate
partially known physics and extract
unknown and new physics maybe there is a
physics of how disease spreads or a
physics of the stock market and we'd
like to be able to understand those the
same way we understand F equals MA
and we'd like to be able to incorporate
our partial knowledge into those models
and in general that's these are
challenges with all machine learning
methods but I think these are actually
particularly challenging and neural
networks but because of how powerful and
expressive and just the incredible
technological advances that have been
made because of neural networks these
are especially important to learn how to
incorporate into neural network
architectures the good news is lots of
great people are working on this you all
should work on this it's really really
vital and pressing especially if we're
gonna have you know self-driving cars
and autonomy and robots and you know if
we ever want to get towards you know
from kind of human guided learning into
a less human guided learning kind of
artificial intelligence we're gonna need
to have generalizability and
interpretability chable machine learning
that incorporates physics and pulls out
new understanding that that can
translate okay thank you